I don't I don't want to choose I can't
put my neck on the line for this one
because I love Backstreet Boys and I
know Timberlake very well but don't know
the NSYNC boys and they both have an
equal level of hit hello GQ I'm Niall
Horan and today I'm going undercover on
the internet
it's actually me
[Music]
Twitter
what has been your favorite part about
coaching on The Voice I think because
I've been on a show like that it made me
go deeper into like trying to be a good
coach I wanted everyone to kind of leave
and feel like they've actually worked
with me and I haven't been just some
famous with their future in my
hands but uh yeah I really enjoyed like
the picking of the songs the camaraderie
between the team and also then the
banter between the four coaches has been
a really good laugh I'm gonna miss the
cowboy Blake Shelton and I'm gonna miss
Clarkson and chance because they're not
doing the next season with me and
Blake's giving up forever next one
Charlotte Claire and London Oris
recently following Niall Horan back on
Instagram I'm sensing a golf match
I did not know this I knew Lando
followed me I didn't know Charlie
claired it too yes I would love to play
golf with those gentlemen I'm a big F1
fan a fan of both of those guys yes I
see a lot of F1 guys playing golf these
days trying to take my thunder Anna
joking let's play next one what do I
have to do for Niall Horan to serenade
me like he's serenading Blake Shelton
tell me I don't know
be nice to me yeah this was a really
good moment in this video me and Blake
just continuing the banter on to even
when we perform they can't put us in any
scenario where we don't mess around but
yeah come to a front row of a gig and
I'll serenade you favorite thing about
Blake um his
lack of fox he's in a deficit of them
I'm gonna miss him big time but I kind
of get the feeling that I could be
friends with him for a while even though
he's 45 years older than me YouTube or
as YouTube as I say here in America oh
no if only he knew what he would achieve
since then it's crazy isn't it don't let
us down I won't hit differently 12 years
later
yeah no it did because if it wasn't for
Katy Perry I would have never I've
gotten through I would never been in the
band anything could have happened there
now knowing what what it's like in the
voice you know she was seeing 40 people
that day and she just said yes at the
right time to me the rest is history as
they say uh pretty cool anyone else
still interpret Nile's hair is blonde
when it's clearly brunette
that's so good yeah sometimes I do so
many people say that to me to my face
and I'm standing there with a brown head
of hair I think I was only like 12 or
13. I remember like the first time I
ever did it I walked in with a picture
of David Beckham and we can pull the
photo up after this and I was like give
me that and like the local hairdresser
did not give me that and I cried but
yeah it's I just spent every three four
weeks sitting in foils four hours at a
time
I fall asleep in the chair I'm not going
back there please as much as we like
blonde Nile he was a nice guy too we're
not going there again thanks
now on to quora
why do singers lose their accent when
they sing Niall Horan for example
I don't know I definitely hear my accent
in some songs for sure but I grew up on
a lot of um like American rock and roll
and American singer songwriters like
from the 70s and 80s and things like
that so I think that like just naturally
watching it and listening to them that's
where I probably got it from what does
Niall Horan sing about in this town it's
basically a song about my hometown I
basically made like a fake relationship
act as a metaphor for my hometown that
no matter where how far I go and how far
I live away from home I'll always end up
you know thinking about my hometown and
and growing up there and in the end
probably pretend to live there at some
point why is Niall Horan afraid of birds
uh let me get this right actually I'm
not afraid of birds I'm afraid of birds
indoors although I don't like pigeons at
any cost but I hate birds inside I
remember one time in the cafeteria at
school there was a bird flying around
when we were all in the line for lunch
and I literally had a panic attack and
nearly collapsed there's something weird
about them well it probably it's
probably because they shouldn't be in
site they're made for the sky not
cafeteria rooms in Christian Brothers
High Schools
who is better Backstreet Boys or NSYNC
that's a rough question quora and
whoever wrote This what I would say is I
know the Backstreet Boys
a lot better than I know the NSYNC boys
but I know Timberlake particularly well
I play golf for Justin Timberlake
there's the biggest name drop of all
time everyone's just gonna think I'm an
songs wise I mean they're in my
head they're like equal
hit for hit I don't I don't want to
choose I can't put my neck on the line
for this one because I love Backstreet
Boys and I know Timberlake very well but
don't know the NSYNC boys they both have
an equal level of hit so I'm not
answering full reviews Instagram
Leon says is this album going to change
my life forever I hope so that's the
idea definitely changed my life when I
was writing it you know now that it's
out in The Ether it's yours now so I I
hope it does to you and to millions and
millions and millions of people around
the world please there's some topics in
there that are definitely relatable I
think we could all do listening to the
show it's basically a song I wrote it in
the pandemic when we were all locked
away and in the chorus I say if
everything was easy and nothing ever
broke how would we realize how good we
had it all along and the first line of
the song is life is like a board game
some of the time so it's like always
making those little moves and to make
sure you get on the right path but we've
got to be grateful here's another one
shows question mark excuse me sir Nile
yes I've just announced a tour for a guy
that was so used to touring the pandemic
really stopped that and it's crazy to
think that I happen towards since 2018
and I'm more fired up than ever to put
on the best show I possibly can I've got
three albums now to play with the set
design that I've got planned is pretty
cool and I can't wait to take it all
over the world and play to as many of
you as I possibly can so go and get your
tickets please
please Wikipedia
[Music]
Horan tried to play the guitar that his
brother bought for his marriage but was
not able to play it poor and then aged
11 taught himself how to play the guitar
by following YouTube tutorials that's a
lie the first part is my brother got a
guitar for his 15th birthday probably
played it once and then it kind of sat
around for a while and then I picked it
up and the second part is very true
unlike dial-up internet you know when it
was like
take like an hour to even get onto
YouTube load a page but I would sit
there and just put on a video of a song
I wanted to play and then like pause it
when they had their fingers set in the
spot the first one I was trying to do
was Wonderwall a minor G
d a I'm still writing songs in those
with those chords today to be honest
with you we all do next one
in the 2013 incident he dislocated his
knee on stage during a concert in antwer
Belgium
wow that's this is deep after the
surgery he was invited to do physical
therapy with Chelsea by their manager
Jose Mourinho Horan went through more
than seven weeks of physical therapy
with the members of the team and their
physical therapist at the training
ground in Surrey how did I notice level
of information they're all it's all very
factual but the depth uh yes very true I
dislocated my knee nine times in about
two and a half years I have a genetic
thing where my kneecap doesn't sit into
its Groove properly so it kind of sits
up like this so it's able to move across
so I dislocated my knee once and it just
kept slipping out because I have
floating kneecap syndrome it's called I
met Jose Mourinho at Real Madrid when he
was the coach there myself and Louis and
Liam went to watch a training session of
theirs met him there and then when I was
getting my knee done I was like I need
somewhere to do some of my physical
therapy and Jose was like come down to
us and then when I got there he had it
all set up brought me into a room with
all the doctors basically explained to
them that I'm one of his players and he
needs me back fit as a football fan I
can't think of anything better than that
I was nearly happy I had a pain in my
knee because I got to spend seven or
eight weeks with the best football
players in the world when I was crutches
and running I used to get in these
little they have these little squares
and they pass it in squares and there's
a guy in the middle and they're trying
to keep it off him and I got in one day
and I never got out it was um very scary
Reddit
foreign
never heard of him in Gossip Pages I'd
like to know more I don't know if there
is any tea I try and live a simple life
when I'm not working can I half keep
them disconnected a little bit while I
was playing golf and like drinking pints
and things like that I'm gonna work at
work I don't really like have tea on me
my boy Niall Horan get him what he
deserves this is so beautiful to see do
you think he had any fairies in going
solo did I have any fears uh of course
the fear of it going wrong and not
having a career is there forever that's
one you can't get rid of try not to
think about that too much because that
would fry my brain however I just had to
trust that I could write a song which I
kind of feel like I can do trust in in
being myself when I go to do it and hope
that the core fan base will turn up the
gigs and then try and grow it from there
but no apart from the fact that you're
constantly just thinking the whole way
through your career how when or how this
is going to end apart from that no not
really
okay that's it I'm signing off the
internet
thank you GQ